(mystical bell-like music)
(staccato instrumental music)
- [Narrator] In the
villages of Guizhou, China,
there is a rich tradition of embroidery.
But perhaps none is more
intricate than that of the Miao.
(lively dance music)
- [Narrator] The Miao don't
have a written language.
Instead, they use their embroidery
to document their history,
legends and culture.
(lively oriental music)
(girls laughing)
(soft instrumental music)
- [Narrator] Miao embroidery
uses incredibly intricate stitching
and hand-spun threads
to create the designs.
Some garments can take years to complete.
- [Narrator] Preserving this tradition
is incredibly important to the Miao.
(soft rhythmic music)
(bell tones)